what's up ramble rouses ram ramble
ramble bunks rolls Ram rambley knows
what's up rambling OHS real quick plug
if you're in the pnw Pacific Northwest
I'll be in Kent Washington March 23rd a
part of the uncanny Comedy Festival in
Kent Washington right outside Seattle
jessimae Peluso will be on that show
Jeff dime Annie Martin and jube all
fresh tickets are available for that now
be a fun time bright cities final season
is airing right now so check out those
episodes and uh you know what watch the
return of Superman it's this YouTube it
was not a youtube series it's this
Korean reality showed as it's very busy
and has a lot going on and it's super
enjoyable anyways here's the episode
[Music]
alright I got a message a few days ago
from an old friend said he was gonna be
in Tampa doing shows my pal a sec what's
up man how's it going it's going alright
are you doing up good good see ya hey
what's happening you know I crazy I
became a dad like a month ago oh yeah
yeah yeah yeah so that's been my life
for the last four weeks that's what is
boy oh boy boy Jackson Jackson yeah
Jackson Palestine yeah that's football
day no I know I don't like football I
play football football be football in
like 13 years there's probably gonna be
Flagg really 13 isn't that gonna be as
is hard-hitting Oh whatever you I think
the rules I think that they can still
play the same way they just have to like
the hits where people are up in there
and out of control I think that's where
where people get hurt my brother played
football in college and he was saying
that's an easier scholarship to get now
because so many kids are going away from
it compared to all the other kids when
you named him Jackson we Hannibal sit as
a dead my name so my obviously but I
guess like like growing up I found out
later like my last name is very my dad's
last name so he just gave my mom the
rights to name all of us it was so like
it was kind of the same was that you
think you gave it up all you decide yes
let you yeah I might have to go through
labor man yeah yeah yeah she my
girlfriend my significant other she ate
a lot of jack-in-the-box when she was
pregnant
okay now is one of the inspirations and
also Michael Jackson and okay Jackson
Hewitt also so you here in Tampa doing
shows yeah yeah how's the show go great
yeah yeah yeah I've been doing this club
for I don't know 10 years now and okay
they do it well like you know you do
different clubs around the around the
road and you're like oh this one this
one kind of could be better
why would I do this one and I feel like
they're doing pretty much I feel like
the best like they do all the press and
like the show times workout and I feel
like they get the drinks out and like
everything seems like it's run pretty
well nice yeah yeah because it can be it
could be a crapshoot yeah it's just so
many different different variables yeah
some clubs you're like oh they're just
trying to make money right now where's
like this club I feels like they want to
have a sustainable and they have they've
been around a long time right we started
around the same time as how about you
still living in Chicago I I live in LA
and you probably
but I get back a lot because my family
is there to welcome their yeah I
remember the first open mic I saw you at
it was your Burton this place burdens
place in Old Town yeah there's birds
dude it was a 40 M bar yeah and I went
there after some other open mic and you
were on stage and there was just like
six comedians in the audience and you
were you were doing joke and then you're
like what would you guys do if I just
went and knocked all these glasses off
the bar right now yeah it was really
funny that was funny early on is that in
those type of rooms when it's just
comics you just start you might do your
bits but then you might just start
saying some weird wackadoodle [ __ ] just
because material isn't working
and they laugh at that and then you
think you could take that to the regular
spots yeah what works at 2:00 a.m. yeah
the lion's den doesn't that necessarily
work at 9:00 o'clock at the comedy club
on a Saturday but sometimes it does and
that's what brings you back like I
remember we did trace
yeah the poetry place I'm so there and
they'd be heckling and they were like it
was like a poetry place for people who
don't know the poetry scene in Chicago
from early mid 2000s and they would like
yell out if you did a joke that you did
the week before oh yeah they didn't like
to hear multiple jokes in a row because
they were poets and did they always do
fresh poems I guess well I know I know a
friend of mine it was a repeat problems
a lot but they were I do remember them
being kind of harsher and judgmental to
the comics I feel like they didn't want
us coming yeah their expectation of the
poet the comedian comedy was a lot
higher than the poetry yeah well I guess
that's kind of know you should be I used
to like doing those rooms though just
because of it would be a better vibe
didn't doing an open mic sometimes
because it wasn't a bunch of comedians
so yeah even if they they would because
I remember getting into some couple
confrontation at those ports you over
Mike's about certain bits or whatever or
people just heckling
but it was uh you know a lot of times it
was just a good crowd oh yeah that's
what I wanted to say like regardless of
all of that I could do a joke there and
if it worked
yeah we're at a club because they're
like real people they're just kind of
jerks yes
so what how how what was your
preparation for fatherhood did you start
reading books listening to father
podcast there's a there's like a video
there's an app you can download called
What to Expect When You're Expecting
yeah and Sam download that on my phone
and so we'd watch there's like a video
every week and you'd watch in and tell
you how your baby was doing and then
there was classes the classes were the
best right he just show up at the
hospital for a couple hours and they
teach you how to like take care of a
baby and all the stuff that's important
I haven't read I we have books like when
something comes up I'll read it but uh
yeah that's the easiest thing it's like
going to a class did she put headphones
on her stomach she was no but we did
like with listen to the Pandora stations
we wanted to listen to and it's funny
now when he's like crying and stuff that
music that she listened to then it
relaxes yeah like he really likes Bob
Dylan on Pandora yes that's his jam song
yeah what does he not like Slipknot we
haven't thrown in the Slipknot seems
like but like baby music he's not like
he is that we have a little rocker that
rocks it itself and there's baby music
on there just like and he doesn't like
that at all oh yeah
but that's supposed to be like
scientifically backed like band music
supposed to make babies feel good no
yeah this one didn't work yeah return
that [ __ ] no it works but like the
rocking is great we just turned the
sound off oh and put on Bob Dylan yeah
yeah got the heck yeah hey man everybody
it's always people always excited to get
that baby to sleep yeah
let's get that baby throw-up gang signs
outside quietly
you still woke do nothing to this baby
sleep then I could just go grab my
machetes and go hunting for pineapples
afterwards when but the baby you gotta
get the baby see do you guys live like
it in a house or like an apartment is an
apartment it's a small so better so if
that baby goes asleep and some other
[ __ ] makes a loud as noise does that
like ruin well I think in a couple
months it will but the first couple
months they just sleep through
everything like we brought him home we
ate dinner we watched a show you sleep
better with the TV on and stuff because
then they'll like move and if they hear
noise then they'll go back to sleep but
if it's quiet then they'll be like oh
something's wrong my parents left oh
yeah this is the two guys that don't
have kids podcast even though I was
almost 36 so yeah a lot of my friends
and people I've known for years I
haven't kids you know I've had kids or
even have teenagers you know kids and
colleges yet but even still when I hear
somebody's having a kid I'm like yeah
yeah that's crazy good for you still yes
around that time that's good [ __ ] yeah
yeah we're excited are you as a
performer and creator now starting to
think about making more children
targeted content because are you already
you've worked you work clean right yeah
but we now the are you thinking ideas
like you know cuz you think about you
know what you have to buy for your son
over the years to keep them entertained
yeah I need to make some of this because
there's other people with babies I mean
for sure and you you look at the books
that people write and baby books are
like 20 pages pictures not a lot of
words and a lot of thoughts yeah like I
have an hour of jokes like so that
people have to laugh
yeah all you need is I something make
you seem like you're making a baby
smarter just use this right one simple
fact and just stress - yeah something
about blue this guy and that those blue
type of red tomatoes are red you just
gotta hit children's market but it seems
like I want out
oh I haven't researched it much but I
remember my sister was talking about
right and she'll just need write a
children's book I don't see much time
you could do as I write a children's
book can I quote Hannibal Buress on the
on the cover but like that's great no
you quote me but it has to be you could
give like a very specific review like
page four was this [ __ ] what anybody
else tells you my son when he's with me
being my son that he can't respond to
fans
oh you're Hannibal jr. and so eight
o'clock Anibal you wanna live off your
parents forever
so Spurs a no do not actually just keep
a stone-faced the method actor not a
little bit but you do not acknowledge
the fandom but as you play my son that's
what I'm that's good yeah write some
children's books yeah yeah I do like
watching I don't know about baby
cartoons but I've always enjoyed
cartoons yeah and I think that'd be cool
at some point to like write something
that everybody and family could watch
together and Joey laughs because you
gonna have to watch yeah so you got a
couple years yeah for he he's gonna get
into it but you got a couple years that
two to three stage way he's really into
it yeah so you might as well make
something yeah you gonna be you you can
make you can get ahead of that yeah
thanks Ong yeah I get what you want you
want to like write or do you want to
direct you want a voice act like what
would you specifically or all of it well
yeah if someone want me to voice act I
would do it for sure but I think we're
I'm at now I would like have an idea and
write it and then and then even though I
would probably get a director I would
have like I don't know I've never made a
cartoon before about to be in the room
and be like this is but it's a cartoon
so you just gotta like draw it how they
want to draw it and then yeah yeah put
it on somewhere and then this is what
we're gonna fix our songs in my head
from watching I don't have kids but from
watching stuff with my cousin kids with
his kids and I still have you just
burning my brain Jay mask that theme
song yeah that format this yeah
what did how did they in a tank is I in
the 90s
just all rattle all day take that
pacifier and a rattle
full of whiskey out of whiskey yeah yeah
sleep aid is whiskey take this battle
[ __ ] please email the handsome Rambler
gmail.com if you currently a parent that
rubs whiskey on the baby's gums to put
them to sleep and this is not out of
judgment I think that's a reasonable
method yes
that's micro dosing for alcohol as a
parent I will say I do not do that yet
yeah yeah because their tolerance isn't
that high right now
you just kind of I think but okay at
this stage I is it child abuse to
breathe alcohol in a baby fit like if
you get if you just drunk is a baby
system that's a good question because I
don't know how much of the breath it
would hurt you like you had the shotgun
I'm like let's say in hay and as you're
talking the liquor spitting onto a space
I do just because like I don't want
anybody to drop the baby that if you've
been under the influence or if you're
doing anything or even if you're really
tired you just put the baby even the
baby screaming just put the baby down
yeah it's fine I'm okay with the baby
crying dude somebody sent a video to
where you know the bear you saw that
Bears kick right what a yeah and so it
was a guy he was holding his kids maybe
two and he was watching the kick and the
guy missed the kick and then yeah yeah
that kicked I just found out recently
that the kick was actually what it was
until even tipped a little bit was it
actually those i've seen the footage and
it's like they counted it as a tip and I
think that was more for the kicker's
health he's like does it really matter
no I don't think they would do that you
don't think they fellas doing stuff and
then they put I saw somebody put up the
stat that I in the past like certain I
forget Robbie Gould 82 of 80
five you know goes in the past they
didn't want to pay him but they didn't
so yeah yeah it was like that's the they
said he was like the second worst and
the whole league oh he's I was at the
Lions game and they missed he missed I
think three field goals and two extra
points maybe there's one less on either
one huh I mean I'm not even really a
football fan like that
bad way I know me too but I can tell bad
kick you know what I'm saying like that
that I said I looked I was like
researching and looking at all those
other kids yeah I'm like this guy don't
know how to kick man how'd they get him
networking well man I think he did well
either as out of college or the year
before cuz they gave him nine million
guaranteed this year and that's why for
one year for one year or might have been
nine million guaranteed but over like
two or three years but he's gets nine
million no matter what oh yeah that's
why I think they rid of him because they
didn't want to like my pin of money it
might be a good that might be some Asian
stuff oh you have some some other high
profile people and he's able to kind of
Coast him by yeah and the kicker they
had the year before was hope they went
through like two or three kickers last
year so yeah anybody got some cold so
they were that's why they paid for it
but he was he struggled yes it's hard to
be a kicker
so that's just I say that to say you
know don't just put your kid down on a
baby you kid win sports time oh yeah I
hold my home I did though I admit to
this I had a show in Wisconsin on
Saturday and I booked my flight late on
Sunday so like it didn't miss the game
so I did dude I wasn't there for my
child but someone was there say somebody
yeah somebody is there well at least
without I think it'd do probably a few
hours there were two people in the
apartment yeah at that time so you're
not supposed to leave on have you ever
thought about you know just greatness
based and putting it you know making it
safe for some food and drink in there
enough and then just put some cameras in
there and there's no chance that a baby
hurting themselves but just see how they
do solo but they be they can't feed
themselves at that point
that's but yeah they figure it out
do they figure it out durable you just
hang the milk down let you put the stuff
in there and just what the human part of
them just say you know ya know how to do
this but I got to get it done what they
that's what I mean yeah I think I mean I
think they might die because like babies
can't sit up right away like maybe in a
couple months and they can move around a
little like three sub now is okay if
it's been that long and they haven't
grabbed a food a problem yeah they can
they can they they should eat that like
every three hours I think okay yeah yeah
I mean I've been trying to get into
science just shining into the science
human observation reading parents
listening I think it's good to to be in
the same area as your child just in case
they misinterpreted something I said
also and any parents listening just know
tell to other parents that this is the
go-to podcast for in the middle of a
rebrand welcome I'm in that line now so
sorry Auto this just adjust with me as I
we're gonna be discussing Bubble Guppies
episode sweet hi we know it's funny when
we're in Maui I had said something about
kids or something and we were we were
hanging out with a little rel a little
rel was like that sounds like some [ __ ]
somebody that don't have a kid would say
[Laughter]
yeah yeah three kids oh yeah good for
him yeah so that's that's what's up yeah
what's your website man it's Michael
Powell that come check out Mike at
Michael Palace SATCOM good luck with the
rest of the shows yeah you too thanks
for coming to me yeah thanks yeah
thanks Mike coordinated hi like you guys
had to make sure it was on for like here
we go
[Music]